what's going on ladies and gentlemen we
go watch the fight of the Furious
trailer to die super Bo TV spot why
don't you ever just went wrong well I'm
just under think about that family
cousin feeling so brutal down the right
or work where I got if you gotta catch
doc you're gonna need a little help you
want tell me why you just put me in a
room with this criminal nothing that
could be shall trample second like
sandhill cranes get me the sign you guys
are going to work together oh oh
[Music]
ejaculated no no that trailer was
ridiculous I love it it is so silly the
death count in this movie is through the
roof how is this pg-13 because there's
no blood so many people are dying you
know how this trailers make these
trainers are making it go like this
what's Dominic Toretto up obviously he's
being controlled or manipulated in some
way but I wonder if the movie is gonna
actually make you wonder that for a
significant period of time and then
revealing I'm kind of feeling that the
movie will tell us a little early on
actually but I think you'd be cool it's
like the movie somehow managed to
convince us for a while even in
something that Dominic Toretto might
actually be a bad dude they's not we all
know that Jason Statham I love it when
you just see celebrities on the same
screen together it could be like Pacino
and De Niro and heat or it could be like
Tom Cruise and Seth MacFarlane on the
graham norton show it doesn't matter as
long as if you see a free celebrities
together there's something kind of cool
without seeing like the rock and Jason
Statham to very popular action stars in
America today or the world actually the
rock more of the world in Jason Statham
occur Russell who's known for allowing I
think it's better actor than both of
these guys but he's done some really
memorable action roles as well there was
something rather special about seeing
all three of them and that one shot
together the way its action sequence
even though there's cars were just
falling out of that garage whoa what is
going on I don't know like Vin Diesel
said it about furious 7 and then he said
something about this to like you know oh
he thinks this could win best picture I
get a nomination or something I don't
know what he's talking about i just
don't see that ever happening ever yeah
the marketing of showing all the crazy
all the craziness is grave and this film
looks like this could be the crazy as
what I love that I love knowing that
were eight films in and this could be
crazier than the last one to get a lot
of them was pretty ridiculous as well I
mean you got like the whole subway thing
you got rockets and missiles and as
people with the moon
Alan guns killing people on the street
holy [ __ ] there's so much craziness
going on in this it looks like a blast
of me I'm really wondering what they're
doing with charlize theron character
though because she's clearly the main
villain they thought the first trailer
and they're not really showing her
talking about her that much I wonder if
she's really going to be utilizing this
film nobody charlize theron like yeah
she won the Oscar for monster and that
was a villainous role in some ways the
main character but you know what I'm man
tire I just think it snow white and the
huntsman the reindeer games when I think
of charlize theron as a villain hard for
me to believe her as a bad person oh
she's too hot that's for prompt too hot
you can't buy a hot girls of Dylan why
the be a villains are hot hot girls I
mean to be bad they're hot they got any
museum life every hot girl has it even
the basic fact of life now if they made
charlize theron look like the way she
wasn't monster then I could see how she
could be a bill was kidding I know hot
girl struggle with real things too
sometimes they're much smaller than most
people but they still struggle alright
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects follow
me on instagram and twitter at the Gregg
Alva I'm Greg Alva goodnight Jay Leno